Disney night on American Idol means a
few things the happiest place on earth
amazing talent and of course Katy Perry
in costume I wanted all of their points
KP did not come to play she fully
committed every inch of her ensemble to
look exactly like the iconic Disney
villain Ursula from The Little Mermaid
crazy hair tentacles even purple face
paints I'm in my trailer looking like me
and somebody good Katie's gonna be
Ursula I'm like she is she purple all
over and they're like she's purple Katie
even flexed her acting skills giving us
her best Ursula impressions all night
that's been here since 9:00 a.m. without
a quitter if she sings well enough I'll
give her one of these thingamabob
[Music]
like Ursula is a character that isn't
done very much in Little Mermaid she
always gets her moment in this side and
there's what actually really just wants
you know Ariel's voice that's all I want
[Music]
[Applause]
but it's not the first time the singer
has dazzled in Disney duds moment of
appreciation for Katie's get up from
last year no I would never say what
she's thinking right now or else she
wouldn't be a part of the Disney family
it was a big night for the contestants
as the competition got whittled down
from the top ten to the top eight Alyssa
Raghu who Katy saved last week scored
the final seat I'm here and you know it
was great pressure I like that I kind of
needed that to push me in the right
direction
the judges have one save they can use
before the season is over but they chose
to not use it on the bottom two
contestants
Demetrius Graham and OJ who were both
eliminated we tried our best and and you
know things happen but you know this is
it the last of each a nor Demetrius and
I mean we're just so excited and today
was great how can I not smile I'm so I'm
so blessed and I'm so thankful and I'm
so proud of all of my friends
like become so far 1,000 people off this
show there's only 10 people out we have
to narrow it down we brought them back
we saved them it was so difficult for me
to say no but in this case it was
necessary
[Music]